hey guys I want to give you a quick tip
on how to get kids off of sugar an
average child consumes 66 pounds of
added sugar every single year that's
added sugar that's not even talking
about the the breads the pasta the
cereal the crackers they you know the
hidden sugars that people don't realize
this is added sugar
you have sweetened milk sweet and
chocolate milk sweetened tea fruit
juices sodas sport drinks vitamin drinks
it's in so many things not to mention
ketchup sauces breaded meats chicken
fingers you name it
okay so here's the goal we want to take
the child from burning sugar to burning
fat this is going to improve the mood
the cognitive function the ability to
learn it's going to stabilize the blood
Sugar's it's going to do a lot so this
is going to be really important and the
problem is it's kind of like an on/off
switch not a dimmer switch you can't
necessarily do this gradually in other
words you can't get someone the ketosis
by just reducing the sugars we have to
eliminate the sugars because in the
presence of just a little bit of insulin
ketosis is nullified what you're going
to end up with is reducing sugars but
they're still going to crave and you're
still gonna have low blood sugars like
that constantly up and down up and down
so the best way to do it is to
substitute the sugar with something
almost identical and that's going to be
like the keto friendly cookies the keto
friendly pies in the sugar free
chocolate and the keto bombs which are
basically these cookies made out of fat
if you provide those foods as a dessert
and not allow the child to have like
starches like french fries then you're
going to finally make the transition
it's going to take like two to three
days of getting the child off sugar to
the point where they're doing really
really well
you might even want to make a cookie
with nutritional yeast to get that
nutritional yeast in their body okay but
you're just going to use things like a
wreath rotol stevia is either tall as
your sweetener
that way the child doesn't really know
that you're switching it there you're
just going to go ahead and oh in stead
of this we're gonna give you this today
okay and what'll happen after three days
they'll adapt to fat running their moods
going to be much much better and it's
going to be easier and easier and easier
so the key is preparing for this I'm
gonna put a link down below of a lot of
different recipes that you can make you
can start out making all sorts of keto
bombs and eventually even have your kids
help you make them and then what you do
is in one day you just eliminate all the
junk food in the house all the sugar all
the hidden sugars and it's just not
there and you have just the keto bombs
okay and then you make the transition
that way so make the change and start a
new trend with your family hey I
appreciate your attention and if you're
enjoying these videos go ahead and
subscribe and I will definitely keep you
updated on future events live events and
webinars that we're going to do very
soon